[Musique]
le musée de l'air et de l'espace du
bourget la présente comme simple légère
et sur la demoiselle est une invention
d'alberto santos dumont l'aviateur
brésilien est mis à l'honneur à bois
d'arcy il a fait des essais pendant à
peu près trois ans sur la ville d'obo
d'arcy sur un terrain d'ailleurs qui
partait de son hangar qui se trouvait
sur la commune de bonnard ciné qui aller
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il allait
jusqu'à saint cyr l'école il reste rien
de matériel du passage de santos dumont
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à l'époque il avait un hangar en bois
bien évidemment les hangars a disparu
aujourd'hui il se trouverait à peu près
là où se trouve le centre de contrôle du
centre leclerc à bois d'arcy
concepteur et pilote il battra plusieurs
records dont celui de bagatelle en 1906
avec 1 14 bis il franchira de 120 mètres
à travers archives et maquettes
l'exposition vous plonge dans l'histoire
de cet inventeur c'est notamment le
créateur de la montre-bracelet jusque ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que au début du
siècle les aviateurs avaient démonté
montre gousset me les montre gousset en
avion c'est pas très pratique donc il
avait demandé à son ami louis cartier
pour ne pas te publicité de lui faire
une mousse nous montre bracelet qui est
en fait donc
il attribue cette invention donc à 2 par
cette commande en marge de cette
exposition une stèle commémorative vient
d'être dévoilée sur la commune